[Musica]
anita che cos'era
è
[Musica]
ma che è stato re di pesce
[Applauso]
che cos'è quello uno squalo un pescecane
ora spero di gr verità deve salvarsi
ecco salvarti dallo squalo verità cosa
che è successo ti ho mangiato lo squalo
aiuto devo fare qualcosa è venuto l'idea
aspetta lì
lascia la lascia la buona vitalità detto
io salvati
cos'è questo è a quota così come la sua
coda è la mia cosa da si rese ho
mangiato no non è nessun pescecane non è
nessuno squalo e che cosa ho trovato
questa nel fondo della piscina
l'ho indossata e mi ha trasformato in
una sirena ma ci pensi ha rivelato il
vero questo modo da sir era andato io
tendo conto ora usciamo fuori dalla
psiche ti faccio vedere bene la coda da
sirene ok ti aiuta gli occhi ma come ho
fatto a trasformarsi in sirena
te l'ho detto ho trovato questo sandolo
nel fondo della piscina
l'ho preso e l'ho indossato e mi ha
trasformato in una sirena mai provato a
toglierlo
magari ti ritornano le gambe normali
proviamo e trasformazione
ma non succede niente no non funziona
come un pazzo non posso vivere con la
coda da sirena non potrò mai più
camminare
aspetta aspetta aspetta lascia mai
pensare un attimo
devo spremere il mio cervelletto no
niente una soluzione
tu non sta qui è non andare da nessuna
parte aspetta aspetta mi che ritorno ok
arrivo subito
[Musica]
citare uccelli pesci sirene
ecco cosa devo fare acqua calda in
padella sale tagliato in cubetti e
permetto cielo
[Musica]
avevo un acqua sul fuoco
un'altra soluzione è fare della cucina
perché è un letto sul libro che con il
pesce ci vuole sale aspetta un ultima
soluzione l'ultima luce tra un provetto
ultima l'ultima
[Musica]
ergo per poterlo così la puoi fare
allora la coda così tv crescono le gambe
salsi certo via no ricrescono basta non
voglio più saperne delle tue soluzioni
riporta mino ok va bene qui
sì grazie
lasciami un momento da sola ok
[Musica]
ci sono dobbiamo andare al mare perché
dobbiamo andare al mare ho sentito il
rumore del mare nella conchiglia e
quindi forse vuol dire che ci sta
chiedendo di portarla al mare cioè di
riportarla al mare ottima idea
finisco le patatine andiamo subito ma la
vita si sicura che al mare troveremo la
risposta ma io spero proprio di sì
tutt'al più si mangeranno gelato
[Musica]
ti aspetto quando
no
[Musica]
ciao vita e al 26 arrivata
ti sei mai resa conto che non è facile
essere una serena così come non è facile
per mille abitanti del mare vivere nel
nostro ambiente
[Musica]
io posso farti tornare come prima
dobbiamo solo aggiustare le cose dare al
mare ciò che nel mare di riprenderti ciò
che appartiene con gli essere umani e
ricorda non esitare a tornei per
aiutarci a prevenire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tra un bagarino ciao
[Musica]
finito
ce l'ho fatta sono di nuovo l'essere
umano le gambe come hai fatto
dovevo riportare al mare ciò che del
mare
riprendere dal mare ciò che appartiene a
noi esseri umani ma che bello finalmente
adesso possiamo andare a prendere un
gelato
andiamo dai
[Musica]
cosa che mi ha toccato un polpo è questo
che cos'è vitale
[Musica]